what role does sexual fantasy have
in the human condition
there's a book called the erotic
imagination it's a very psychoanalytic
book written by a psychoanalyst that
talks about
how
well here's the uncomfortable reality
freud was at least right about one thing
which is that the brain circuitry that
you used
to develop attachments to your
caregivers mother and father or other
caregivers
do not disappear when you hit puberty
they are repurposed for romantic and
sexual relations
and so this is why the whole notion of
anxious attached and secure attached you
know stems from childhood attachment
patterns but it carries over to romantic
relationships so that the relationship
with your mother has
and father has a
and probably other close people to you
and your young age
has
a
secondary tertiary some kind of ripple
effect on how your sexuality developed
like what fantasies you might have all
that oh without question and of course
early experiences too and traumatic or
positive or neutral the thing that's
really important to remember though in
this transfer of circuitry from one role
to another is that
and it's certainly consistent with
psychoanalysis that gender is
interchangeable
sex is interchangeable so for instance
let's say you had a wonderful
relationship let's say this hi let's
take a hypothetical person okay i'm
truly not referring to myself let's take
a a a young woman who has a wonderful
relationship to her father
and a just absolutely terrible abusive
relationship to her mother just for sake
of example
she then goes into adulthood and
she is drawn to very abusive
men not always but let's just use in
this example
and the dynamic is exactly the same as
the dynamic she had with her mother
that's actually a common occurrence even
though
in this context she's heterosexual she's
romantically attracted to men what is
seen over and over again is that the
dynamic with one parent can be
transferred onto a romantic dynamic but
it doesn't have to be you know that if
it was with the mother then it only has
to do with relationships to women so
gender is interchangeable because these
circuitries
are pre-sexual they're laid down in our
brain before the brain has any concept
of sexual interactions it's pre-pubertal
excuse me
and so um there are a lot of interesting
examples and data to support this um
the book attached is a pretty
interesting book by two psychologists
one i think is at columbia university um
that talks about how childhood dynamics
uh carry over to adult uh romantic
attachment so as you can tell i get
pretty alert in response to these
questions i get a lot of them relate in
this domain and they have a lot of
impact on people and they're wondering
about they want to learn and no one
knows what other people are doing or
what's normal we kind of know deviancy
we know perversion we know the extremes
yeah we know the rules hopefully people
know the rules but
you know
let's just be there are a lot of people
in in the academic community in
particular at certain east coast schools
not to be named that are in open
relationships this is more common now
um it's not
very common but it's more common yeah
and
you know obviously that's a way of
bypassing some of these more primitive
emotions about jealousy etc and
leveraging them towards maybe even
ongoing relationships i'm not passing
judgment one way or the other i always
say
four conditions have to be met for any
discussion about about sex and sexuality
or sexual health age appropriate
context appropriate
consensual and species appropriate
you